you walked out and I was struck
immediately you look good you it looks
like you've lost some weight what's
going on I have I lost 60 pounds yeah
he's huge I'm still gross but like I
still have tits and I have this gross
gut with an Audi belly button like I
went through the Total Recall machine at
the airport and the dudes like sir he's
still wearing a belt I'm like no it's my
body my body made a belt to keep my guts
from falling out well do you feel better
a lot of people say they feel better
when they lose that kind of way I do but
I still I still ruin toilets oh yeah
that was like when I was 320 that was my
superpower destroying toilet this next
sentence is not even a joke my
brother-in-law will not let me in his
house story he lines were drawn rules
were made and precedents that he had to
go to Home Depot three times because of
me my whole family knows now you all
know thank God he doesn't host
Thanksgiving cuz no guarantees you know
what I'm saying you don't think that
would go well if ya know you put a
turkey in my tummy I'm putting a turkey
in your tire God it's how the body works
come and I now wait a minute is this a
problem when you go on the road when you
actually travel I have I actually I
destroyed a toilet in Edmonton Alberta
less I'm here it's like you're a fighter
days you're listing your kills you say
with a great pride that killed a kohler
toilet in Ontario what home I have
plungers plural form of the word plunger
indicating more than one plunger you
know what I mean but I should fly with a
plunger put it in the overhead
but put in a guitar case so I look super
cool nerds but steely like do that
blunder I'm like nah it's a Jackson be
brother no no you can't do that in my
face and have me agree with you right no
okay right you're right you're right
yeah right now right so yes you go on
the road and you bring a plunger yeah
that's the idea but I didn't in Edmonton
so I had to involve total strangers in
my nightmare it's true I called
downstairs when I go hey I called the
toilet and I know I didn't smile in real
life I'm pretty sure I shed a single
tear at the end of that sentence clog
the toilet bloop I said to the woman I
said hey can you please send a dude up
and I should have been more specific
because that's all she did is set a dude
up not a dude with a plunger or a plan
or idea just a dude I swear to god he
looked at my toilet full of turds and
left I swear to you he just watched it
and goes that's gross see ya I do not
blame him but not at all they grab
someone on the street I think he quit do
I think yeah I think he left the country
because they they sent up a second guy
and the second guy has the plunger and
I'm excited to see the plunger because
he knows why he's there and on a mission
Yeah right he won't believe what he said
to me because I still don't he goes
where is it
where is it dude you're fired Dungeon
Master on the hole okay Brian Posehn
you